there's a graphic now going around on
social media ten ways you can actively
reject your white privilege the people
pushing this are serious and then they
suggest that we must all abide by the
strictures recommended in this post if
we wish for a better country
so let's deconstruct this nonsense okay
number one says take up minimal space
during anti racism dialogues and
protests minimal space I don't know
that's supposed to mean should white
people who don't like themselves put
themselves in like mine boxes should
they take alice-in-wonderland potion and
shrink down or better yet should they
simply stop showing up what's the big
worry here man spreading intimidation of
the people who happen not to share skin
color but who share the same ideas
regarding politics I'd recommend that
leftist lighten up but they'd probably
think that was racist
they said they then say second stop
contributing to gentrification and
calling it urban development stop
investing in down trodden areas and
building nice homes and shops people
keep those downtrodden areas racially
segregated at least they're historic the
last thing we would want is people in
those historic areas to have jobs and
safer neighborhoods and nice restaurants
they must be relegated to poverty for
the sake of the character of the place
three listen when people call you on
your microaggressions I suppose this
means not jumping from the nearest
window which is actually kind of a
sacrifice for never invite people of
color to the table for the sake of
claiming diversity I actually agree with
this one how about we just invite people
to the table who are interesting and
have knowledge rather than judging them
by their skin colour but you know
doesn't agree Hillary Clinton she
actually suggested having a black person
to be named later in her cabinet for the
sake of claiming diversity five and
refrain from using your non-white
friends as your urban dictionary not
sure who does this who turns to their
black friend and asks them to decode rap
songs anybody then again if you actually
talk about black cultural hallmarks and
you're not black then your white
splaining or you're engaging in cultural
appropriation so it's a little bit of a
catch-22 six stop lifting up
non-confrontational people of color as
example of what people of color activism
should be stop talking about Martin
Luther King jr. instead let's pretend
that the Black Panthers and early
Malcolm X we're better examples of black
liberation even if they actually
resulted in you know counterproductive
backlashes that hurt their causes it's
not like nonviolent resistance is
actually succeeded in America or
anything seven call your friends family
and co-workers out on racism even if a
person of color isn't in the room this
actually seems like a good idea like
this post that
discussing right now it's racist Hey
understand that all anti-racism work
doesn't look the same and advocate
accordingly
this means that you should let everybody
do what they please up to and including
riots in Ferguson presumably nine
realize that all discussions about race
aren't for you and be okay with it
you see if you're called racist or for
discussing racism you should shut up as
your white it's not for you yes about
you and yet you're the problem
and yet you suck but shut up that's not
racism you know to tell white people to
shut up
when discussing how much they suck
that's rejecting white privilege it's
your privilege to speak so we have to
reject that privilege 10 recognize that
you're still racist no matter what well
I mean to be honest this sort of defeats
the purpose of points one through nine
we could you skip to this one and then
do whatever we want anyway since we'll
never actually be able to escape our
white privilege so thanks leftists for
ensuring that racism lives on and
forcing people to shut up based on skin
color you've done us all a real service
at least in exposing your own more
illuminated nasai Manship hero this is
the Ben Shapiro show
you know every time you think that
you've actually parodied the left
sufficiently they parody themselves and
it all goes out the window I want to
talk a lot about Trump care today
because the new Congressional Budget
Office report is out and it basically
sucks there's a bunch in it that is not
true or there's a bunch in it that is
based on faulty premises and the entire
left is going totally insane over it and
clearly there is a division of opinion
about the CBO report from the right as
well you have some people like Paul Ryan
who are touting the CBO report because
he hit his head on something hard when
he was a child and he has some people in
the Trump administration saying the CBO
report doesn't mean anything even though
they used to cite the CBO report about
Obama we'll get to all of that in just a
second but first we have to say thank
you to our sponsors at Bull and branch
so if you are somebody who really does
not sleep well one of the reasons you're
not sleeping well I would guess is
because the quality of your sheets is
terrible I know this because this was my
problem I used to sleep on the most
uncomfortable sheets I mean it was like
stuff that you bought at the local
7-eleven in the parking lot from the
shady guy who probably stole it from a
truck similar and it was all garbage and
I'd know the difference you know they
say thread count a thousand a thousand
is better than 900 that means that that
is an awesome sheet and it turns out
that it actually is just the tarp that
the homeless guy used to cover the the
dumpster and back in the store well
actually if you want a solid sheet you
know like a sheet that is going to allow
you to breathe it's a breathable sheet
they're really comfortable they're so
comfortable I've now bought I think
three or four pairs of these on my own
because they're so good bull and branch
sheets are the place to do it I think
three ex-presidents sleep on bull and
branch sheets plus Bill Clinton's lovers
presumably you'll be so comfortable that
you will fall asleep faster and you'll
sleep deeper and you will wake up
refreshed which is a big thing if you're
not getting enough sleep if you if you
work hard bull and branch eats are
absolute quality they're crafted from
100% organic cotton they also look
fantastic they are better looking sheets
than the crap that you're likely to get
at your local save on so make sure that
you over to Boleyn branch calm right now
and they are cheaper than most of the
designer customer sheets because they
are really it's direct-to-consumer so
it's really it's it's terrific stuff I
can't I can't praise their products more
highly Boleyn branch calm today
bol L and branch calm today you'll get
$50 off your first set of sheets plus
free shipping when you use the promo
code Ben so use that promo code been the
usually like some of them are like 200
bucks so that means that if you get a
$50 discount you're getting a pretty
steep discounts on that and you do that
when you use promo code Ben sounds like
a lot of money it really isn't the
sheets are really high-quality they're
gonna last you for a really long time
plus they're so good that you're not
gonna want to sleep on anything else
they definitely spoil you Bowl and
branch calm today bull and branch calm
Bo LL and branch calm promo code then
use that promo code Ben to get the $50
discount plus it means that they know
that we sent you which is helpful to the
podcast already so let's jump right in
here so the CBO comes out with its new
report on the the Obamacare replacement
bill and it is not a flattering report
it is not a good report and you wouldn't
expect it to be a good report because
the bill is actually really not a good
bill as I've stated before there are a
bunch of problems with the bill so it's
not a shock that the CBO didn't like the
bill but let's go through some of the
things that are in the bill so Robert
Cray check over at today Lee Weyer has
pretty good breakdown when what's in
this thing the stuff that Republicans
liked is that the deficit is supposed to
go down so right now that's important
because there are certain bills in place
that say that if the CBO estimates that
costs will go up then it's very hard to
pass a bill if you say that see if the
CBO says the costs will go down then
it's easier to pass a bail one of the
reasons this is stupid is because the
CBO is wrong about pretty much
everything the CBO report on Obamacare
is just incorrect when they estimate
that a lot of coverage is gonna happen
through Medicaid they're assuming a
bunch of states are going to expand
their Medicaid in accordance with
Obamacare they're not doing that so
there are so many states that haven't
joined Medicaid will join Medicaid or
expand their Medicaid rather and that's
not happening so the CBO reports are
very very flawed but the CBO here
estimates the budget deficit will be 559
billion in fiscal year 2017 but they say
that the American Health Care Act this
is Trump care would reduce federal
deficits 337 billion dollars over nine
years now the real number is like over a
trillion dollars over the next nine
years but then we give a bunch of tax
cuts they say that this takes away from
the government so it actually is only
going to reduce the deficit by about 400
billion three hundred thirty-seven
billion now there's a problem with this
- which is that it's assuming that
everything is going to stay the same the
level of subsidy is going to stay the
same Congress is not gonna come along
and try and fill in coverage gaps by
providing bigger subsidies or bigger tax
credits
I don't actually believe that the
deficit is going to really drop under
the spill because there has never yet
been a government subsidized program
where the deficit decreases it just
doesn't happen that way the bill the CBO
also says that the that the number of
uninsured is going to rise so by 2018
they say 14 million more people would be
uninsured than under current law
according to the CBO's estimate and they
say that most of this 14 million person
increase would be people who are
currently purchasing health insurance
because they are forced to do so by the
government and then they would just stop
doing it because they don't want to pay
the penalty so the left is jumping on
this to suggest that people are being
thrown off their health insurance no
most people just don't want to buy the
stupid stuff because it's too expensive
and it's crap and once they're not
forced to buy it they will stop buying
it and we'll talk about this in a little
while because the left keeps saying now
that this means people are going to die
people are going to die because of Trump
care no they say that by 2026 fifty two
million people would be uninsured
according to their estimate and they
estimate there would only be twenty
eight million people if the status quo
of the of the Obama care administration
was maintained there is a problem with
this however okay so I will explain this
problem with this chart here is a this
is 18 CBO and this is that this is what
the CBO estimated would be the
enrollment in Obamacare over time right
and so what you can see here if you're
if you're watching is you can see
several different lines right you can
see that there's the CBO's estimate as
of 2010 the CBO estimate as of 2012 the
CBO's estimate as of 2014 and then you
have here the CBO's estimate of 2016 and
finally have the actual right then you
have the actual so as you can see the
actual is much much much lower than what
the CBO estimated so they estimated that
by this time that they estimated that by
2018 if 18 million people would suddenly
jump into the Obamacare pool from 12
million that they estimate now and
really at only 10 million now originally
in 2010 when Obamacare passed they
estimated the 22 million people would
already have enrolled in Obamacare okay
right now it's 10 million people so
clearly the CBO doesn't know what it's
talking about because you can't forecast
these things they were including that
the way the CBO estimates these things
they take sort of the projections of the
administration at issue and they and
they carry out their assumptions but if
the assumptions are bad
assumptions are bad you can see how bad
these assumptions are if you want to
know what exactly how bad the CBO is at
this look at that blue line all right
look at that blue line and the black
line because those are the CBO estimates
and then look at that green lines you
see the giant disparity between the
Green Line and the blue and the blue and
black line up top that's how badly the
CBO got this wrong on Obamacare and now
they're saying that there's gonna be
this great discrepancy between Trump
care and Obama care one of the ways that
you drive up the gap between what they
estimator will be and what Obama care
will be is by following the red line but
look the red line still isn't the Green
Line see there's this giant gap 78
million people between what is more
likely to happen with the Obamacare
exchanges and what is and what the CBO
estimates so what the CBO is doing is
they're using that red line and then
they're contrasting it with what Trump
care would do when really they should be
using the Green Line and contrasting it
with what Trump care would do and that
is a much much smaller gap okay the the
CBO also says that health insurance
companies are not going to survive so
despite all of the talk from Trump and
team about how this is gonna free up the
market it doesn't actually free up the
market they say that the market for non
group coverage insurance purchased
individually would be unstable if the
people who wanted to buy coverage in any
offered price would have average
healthcare expenditures so high that
offering the insurance would be
unprofitable in other words without a
mandate and this was the reason there
was an Obamacare mandate without a
mandate you don't have healthy people
buying in because healthy people don't
buy health insurance typically or at
least expensive health insurance if you
don't have healthy people buying in that
drives up the cost of health care for
all of the other people who actually are
sick because it costs more to insure
sick people than to bundle them together
with healthy people and that means costs
go up and people are thrown off their
insurance that means the premiums are
gonna rise and that's what the CBO
estimates they say that the premiums in
the individual market will rise before
2020 and then they say that it will
decrease after 2020 because a bunch of
people will basically be covered by
Medicaid expansion up to 2020 and also
because they think that they think the
competition at that point will kick in
and finally you'll see the premiums
decrease the problem is 2020 is four
years off from now three years off from
now and there's no guarantee that that
happens and then finally the CBO says by
the way we don't know what we're talking
about here's what the actual report says
it says the ways in which federal agency
states insurers employers individuals
doctors hospitals and other affected
parties would respond to the changes
made by the legislation are
difficult to predict so the estimates in
the report are uncertain but everybody's
taking it as gospel so number one you
shouldn't take it as gospel that's just
let's be frank about this the CBO as we
show in this chart the CBO really is not
correct here and they don't know always
what they are talking about it is
perfectly fair to question the CBO's
forecast based on their history of bad
forecasts that's not stopping Democrats
from going out there and pointing out
that a bunch of people are quote-unquote
going to lose their health insurance now
I want to start with this premise for
one second and pause and when they say
that people are gonna lose their health
insurance people gonna die because they
lose their health insurance if your only
metric of health care success is how
many people are covered by any health
insurance program whether it sucks
whether it's Medicaid then what that
means that in the end the only way
you're actually going to get to the
number you want is through nationalized
health care if your only measure of
success is how many people are
quote-unquote covered and it doesn't
matter what the type of coverage is and
it doesn't matter what the quality of
coverage is it doesn't matter everybody
whether you can actually get a doctor
through the coverage if that's all that
matters to you the nationalized health
care is the only solution because
nationalized healthcare means that
everyone's covered sure the health care
coverage is crappy sure you can't
actually benefit from the health care
coverage but everybody is covered and
you see the left jumping into this they
say that Obamacare is better than Trump
care because Obama care quote-unquote
covers more people but there's no
evidence that that coverage is actually
making health care outcomes better and
there's a reason for that
first of all when you don't have health
insurance in America it's not like you
die on the street very virtually
everybody who has a health care problem
in the United States walks into an
emergency room right as well immigrants
do in the state of California
overburdening the system so the idea
that the alternatives are either have
some sort of government provided health
insurance or you die in the waiting room
it's just not true it's just not true
beyond that the vast majority of doctors
actually don't accept Medicaid because
Medicaid doesn't reimburse at proper
rates there are studies that actually
examine whether Medicaid increases life
expectancy and what they find is
basically no so there's something called
the Oregon health insurance experiment
that actually looked at this in Oregon
and it found that it did not decrease ER
visits so one of the purposes of having
Medicaid is the idea okay you're covered
now so you don't have to show up in the
ER it actually doubled the number of ER
visits because people thought that
Medicaid just meant they were supposed
to use the ER more apparently and when
Medicaid users received more diagnostic
which is true it also had no
statistically significant effect on
several measures of physical health
including blood pressure cholesterol our
cardiovascular risk so the idea that
being on Medicaid is a life saver and if
you're not on Medicaid you die it's just
not true Jim Garrity at national review
he notes that as of 2015 only 2/3 of
doctors took Medicaid only 45% of
doctors took new patients on Medicaid so
a lot of people have been grandfathered
in Manhattan Institute says quote the
best statistical estimate from the
number of lives saved each year by the
Affordable Care Act Obamacare is zero
certainly there are individuals who have
benefited from various of its provisions
but attempts to claim broader effects on
Public Health and thousands of lives
saved rely upon extrapolation from past
studies that focus on the value of
private health insurance but the ACA has
expanded coverage through Medicaid not
private health insurance in fact public
health trends since the implementation
of Obamacare have worsened because
people have lost the private health
insurance they've been forced onto
Medicaid with 80,000 more deaths in 2015
than had mortality continued declining
at during the 2014 2015 rate achieved
during 2000 to 2013 in other words the
life expectancy in the United States in
2015 under Obamacare actually decreased
for the first time in two decades
so since 1990 life expectancy has been D
has been increasing in the United States
and actually dropped last year under
Obamacare so suggesting that getting rid
of Obamacare will actually kill people
no evidence to suggest that's the case
at all and we have to pause here to say
hello and thank you to one of our
sponsors over at my Patriots apply so
right now if your concern North Korea is
talking about launching nuclear missiles
at the United States this is a real
serious thing like they're actually
talking about doing this they're
bragging about it all the time most of
us kind of write that off okay what's
the big deal they're never gonna do it
well they're never gonna do it until
they do it you know disaster never hits
until it hits tornadoes blizzards
earthquakes these things don't hit until
they hit and when they do hit you better
be prepared and that's why you need to
talk to my friends over at my Patriot
supply you can give them a call at eight
eight eight eight oh three fourteen
thirteen eight eight eight eight oh
three fourteen thirteen for $99 plus
free shipping you get a four week
emergency food supply people around the
office already try it they say that it
actually tastes really good so it's 99
bucks plus free shipping you can check
it out my Patriot supply eight eight
eight eight oh three fourteen thirteen
go online right now if you're watching
this online go up
pair with Ben comm prepare with Ben calm
that's a four week emergency food supply
and makes sure that you and your entire
family are covered for a significant
period of time following a disaster in
case
emergency services can't get to you in
case you can't have access to the
grocery store in case the grocery stores
have been have been you know not been
supplied properly that's what this is
for it's all just to keep you safe make
sure that you are safe prepare with Ben
calm prepare with Ben calm 888 803 1413
okay so when you hear Democrats claiming
that everybody is going to die because
of Trump care just recognize that that's
a wild exaggeration and it's not
actually true and also the reason that
they are saying this is because they are
conflating health insurance with health
care and by doing so they're basically
pushing for nationalized health care
because if you say that the only way
that America is has a good health care
system is if quote-unquote every single
person is covered you're gonna end up in
a position where you have to cover
everybody through the government that's
just the way that this works the truth
is what you actually want is better
health care outcomes on average through
choice and there are a lot of ways to do
that that don't involve the government
one of the reasons that the United
States still has high life expectancy is
because we developed new products and
services one of the reasons we do is
because we have a private market
understand that what socialism and what
redistribution isn't do is they destroy
innovation they destroy the capacity of
insurance companies to compete with one
another for your services and they
destroy the capacity for pharmaceutical
companies to do research and development
for hospitals to do research and
development for new drugs to be used for
new surgeons to discover new surgeries
what socialism does it freezes things in
place and passes it around and what
capitalism does is it doesn't freeze
things in place and pass it around so
there's more inequality under capitalism
and socialism but it allows innovation
it allows prices to drop and that allows
more people to have access and that is
the important thing now the problem is
that the Trump administration has a real
divide has a real divide when it comes
to how they understand what Trump care
ought to be and you can see that and how
they are dealing with the CBO report
which is really quite fascinating so
Donald Trump is basically on the verge
of suggesting that we ought to just let
Trump care go and let Obamacare implode
which as I said yesterday is not a
solution because entitlement programs
don't implode they just get bigger here
is Donald Trump talking about Obamacare
and it's imploding and 17 will be the
worst view and I said it once I'll say
it again because Obama's gun you know he
things are gonna be very bad this year
for the people with Obamacare they're
gonna have tremendous increases and the
Republicans frankly are putting
themselves in a very bad position I tell
this to Tom Price all the time by
repealing Obama because people are going
to see the truly devastating effects of
Obamacare they're not gonna see the
devastation in seventeen and eighteen
and nineteen it'll be gone by that it'll
whether we do it or not it'll be
imploded off the map so the press is
making it look so wonderful so that if
we ended everyone's gonna say oh
remember how great Obamacare used to be
remember how wonderful it used to be it
was so great it's a little bit like
President Obama what he left people like
them there's actual truth to what Trump
is saying here the press is propping up
Obamacare talking about how wonderful
it's gonna be but the idea that
Obamacare is going to implode yes the
prices are going to skyrocket at a
certain point here because people are
dropping off the rolls because people
are out they'd rather pay the fines than
pay for these high premiums they're
dropping on to Medicaid and so they're
not really paying into the system all of
that's true but that doesn't mean
Obamacare is going to implode it just
means that the media is going to say
more people are covered because they're
dropping from private insurance onto
Medicaid so that's number one but I
think the important gap that you're
seeing here is in between Trump and the
so-called conservatives who you know
like Paul Ryan who really is not super
conservative when it comes to this
particular bill the gap that you are
seeing is that Donald Trump is using the
left's metric for what is a successful
health insurance and health care program
and we'll talk more about that but you
have to go over to Daly wire.com for
that so go over to Daly wire calm right
now become a subscriber we're gonna
deconstruct some culture a little bit
later and talk about that gonna talk
about Michael Brown in this new tape
that is broken up him does it change
everything Daly wired.com to check that
out $8 a month we'll buy a subscription
today is the very last day for annual
subscribers to get a free DVD copy of
the arroyo fictional film set on the
southern border a really good movie
you're gonna want to watch in multiple
times with your family it's really good
Daly wire.com annual subscribers get
that movie today is the very last day
for that deal so daily wired.com $8 a
month plus if you just want to listen to
the show a little bit later then you can
always go over to iTunes or SoundCloud
and check it out and to make sure that
if you go over to iTunes make sure that
you leave a review we really appreciate
it we are the largest conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
you